taliban fighters have opened fire on
demonstrators marking afghanistan's
national day in the capital kabul
opposition to the taliban takeover
appears to be spreading as defiant
afghans raised the national flag in a
growing number of cities but there have
been reports of deaths at some rallies
as the taliban tightened their grip
the taliban have only been in kabul for
a few days but the city has already
changed
on
independence day flying the old national
flag is no longer just an act of
celebration
it's becoming one of defiance
the taliban have replaced it with their
own white banner but that didn't stop
large numbers of people from parading
through the streets with the red black
and green again
sometimes right in front of their new
rulers
[Music]
in some parts of kabul gunshots were
heard during demonstrations
but so far the taliban have showed more
restraint than in other parts of the
country where civilians have been beaten
and killed for participating in similar
protests
since the city fell to the insurgents
crowds of people have come to kabul's
airport every day in desperate hope of
getting out
coalition leaders have made promises to
evacuate those who worked for their
military and diplomatic missions
and several thousand have already made
it out but many more are still waiting
at the airport
[Music]
the situation is very bad and there are
twice as many people inside
no one is getting out of here
even the journey to the airport is
uncertain
taliban fighters are reportedly stopping
and checking cars on some of the city's
streets
turning back some and allowing others
through
most of the people who make it to the
airport can only watch the planes take
off leaving them behind
[Music]
far from the crowded airport some people
have already come a long way from home
to reach temporary camps in kabul's
parks
now they have nowhere left to run to and
supplies are
[Music]
when scarce country is peaceful we will
return to our homes at least then we can
work and eat
in this poverty and helplessness
helplessness
it's in the faces and voices of so many
afghans whose government and security
forces seem to vanish into thin air
their world suddenly turned upside down
straight to kabul now where we join
journalists friends marty who's been in
the thick of it now for days franza
let's start with today's protests and
the taliban reaction what have you heard
there have been rallies for the afghan
flag here on independence day in hamburg
there have also been reports from a
smaller rally in a rural part of kunara
eastern province
it has been like different in kabul in
some instances as you mentioned in the
report taliban where at the scene and
didn't react
uh there in other instances that has
apparently been gunfire from puna there
were even casualties reported yesterday
similar rallies in um assad about
jalalabad and host took also place and
led to different reaction for example in
horse the curfew was imposed that would
seem to be at least partially
caused by this rally on the other hand
the taliban commander also said that
people are allowed to have the flag they
just have submitted to a to an islamic
system
in nangarhar there have even been
pictures that the taliban celebrated
independence day lying down flowers at
the grave of the afghan king that uh
gained independence and the crowd in the
ceremony had also like the the banners
of the or the flags of the republic so
uh different reactions in different
places to different times
does it look like these protests are
gaining momentum
they have spread a little bit in general
it should be noticed though that like
they're still relatively small in number
so we are not talking about mass
protests that threaten to reverse the
taliban takeover these protests are
relatively small nonetheless they are of
significance because they show that
afghan population uh does not just tag
along with everything that the taliban
want to change
that there is this and and now it
remains to be seen how how this is
handled in the weeks to come
what about kabul's airport which has
been the focus of so much chaos in
recent days is the situation there any
clearer
no really um the situation has been
fluid during the past days
sometimes it seemed like it would become
more orderly just to be followed by more
reports of chaos it's also difficult to
pinpoint who's responsible for this or
rather their indication that all sides
are responsible for this the reports
that the taliban have said
uh that people should go home and not go
to the airport taliban have also once or
twice make clear in statements uh that
they want africans to stay and that they
seem it uh i mean it looks bad for them
if everyone wants to leave
on the other hand the the international
forces also seem to be not well set up
there have been examples of people with
all their paperwork being ordered to an
airport gate just to see
uh is he being closed and not being let
in
a source from the airport said that no
embassy stuff is on the ground to
process these people plus then you have
afghans they go to the airport without
any papers uh in in the unrealistic hope
to somehow get out and that also makes
things difficult
franz as you well know one region is
holding out against the taliban and
that's the pangaea valley northeast of
kabul
son of a famed anti-taliban fighter
appears to be trying to raise a
resistance army what's going on there
so far apparently not much
had already before
like start a preparation for resistance
first vice president ambula saleh is
apparently also in the pancho valley and
they try to rally people to what extent
this has been successful uh can't be uh
said there have been like reports on
first skirmishes
um that remained unverified and were
likely inaccurate
um
problem is also it's only punchy so in
the old days when his father resisted
routes to the borders were open so they
they had some supply routes now pancho
is surrounded on all sides by taliban
and there are reports that the taliban
try
uh to negotiate the surrender of pancho
before resistance starts ahmad masood in
today's op-ed in the washington post
vowed to fight uh but whether this will
be possible has to be seen
journalist friends marty in kabul no
doubt we'll hear more from you thank you
so much
for more analysis on the wide-ranging
significance and impact of the taliban
in afghanistan let's turn now to uh mark
turner in humber turner's a journalist
author and afghanistan expert mark thank
you for joining us should the west have
ever gone into afghanistan and if not
why
i think it's rather an academic question
now the rest went in the question for me
is should the west have gone in this
kind of concept i mean the concept first
was labeled nation building then
by the mid
i think 20 26 27 it changed it became
coin counter insurgency and more and
more afghans took it like a kind of
colonial colonial concept this was the
problem
is the
ideology deeply embedded in uh afghan
society and if so how could this shape
afghanistan's political and social
landscape
deeply
no i i wouldn't i wouldn't think so
because you know um
afghanistan has a very very important
cultural and islamic tradition so uh
don't forget that the famous mystic umi
was an afghan it was from the province
so popular
islam in afghanistan is quite
mystical so it's it's not a
fundamentalist it's not the taliban way
taliban islam is an import from pakistan
mixed with some saudi elements so it's
not the popular afghan islam
got it there are people in their 20s and
30s in afghanistan who have grown up in
a democracy
how could this new taliban
administration affect this generation
a democracy i would put some question
marks behind it because you had
warlordism you had
a lot of corruption inside the
government but it's a very big class you
have free
i mean it's a very big achievement that
you had free media and this element free
media is very very popular among young
afghans so i think this is something
that will stay
a g7 meeting was held in london today
and calls were made for a joint global
response to help afghanistan are we
looking at further military conflict you
think
it's possible it's possible if you think
that there are some uh other very
radical groups like islamic state so i
wouldn't exclude that
it could
once again become a military conflict
yes
how much of a threat is the current
situation in afghanistan um to the
international security
yes i think it's
the same point
i'm wondering whether some other radical
groups like the islamic state for
instance i think it's the most important
one will gain influence because the
taliban will not be able to control the
whole of the afghan territory it's very
huge you have mountains
you have deserts so there are a lot of
places where you can hide and for me
this influence
of the islamic state is one of the most
dangerous
things to to
look at the future
that's a mark turner in hamburg thank
you so much
my pleasure
the defense ministry here says the
bundesvara has evacuated more than 1200
people now from afghanistan german
military aircraft are flying people to
tashkent in uzbekistan from tashkent
evacuees travel on to germany on
commercial flights
hugs and huge relief for those arriving
at frankfurt airport
even for those with german passports
getting into kabul airport and onto a
plane to tash kent was an ordeal
they tell of the chaotic evacuation and
of uncertainty about the future of those
left behind
[Music]
the life of an afghan is cheap at the
moment the way the world is treating us
it's a terrible game they're playing in
afghanistan
i'm very thankful of german peoples from
from our colleagues at foreign office
thank you very much you did a lot and i
expected please please continue to help
us i'm worried about my father
my mother and my brothers and my sister
because now i'm not there but they are
in dangers
those without german documents are being
transferred to this clearing center in
brandenburg in the east of the country
around 100 afghans are expected to
arrive here on thursday evening
as far as i know they are mostly local
staff possibly also people who have
reason to be afraid of the taliban such
as people from civil society or
journalists
and we will take care of them as well
they will be given medical assistance
and tested for coronavirus before being
moved to new homes around the country in
the coming days and weeks
the government says it is now doing all
it can to bring out above all those who
worked closely with germany and german
organizations
this is the full common understatement
it is totally without question that the
local staff and their family members
should come to germany we have a moral
responsibility for this
stuff anymore
these people are not refugees or asylum
seekers but rather they will receive
approval to stay from the german
government out of national political
interests
while germany is a new home for some
others are being welcomed by loved ones
what none of those arriving know is when
they might be able to return to
afghanistan
let's hear from dw's asia desk in our
championship
shamil first i wanted to ask you about
some of our very own dw correspondents
who are still stuck in afghanistan we're
hearing that a family of a colleague was
attacked by the taliban what more can
you tell us about that
well the
situation is very dire for journalists
in afghanistan across afghanistan for
all journalists local but those who are
associated with foreign organizations
their lives are in danger
we have many reporters and
correspondents
local reporters and correspondents in
afghanistan and their lives are in
danger their families lives are in
danger they have been threatened
harassed and attacked by the taliban and
in one case one of our colleagues who is
in germany his family has been attacked
and a
family member has been killed
and one is wounded the situation is
extremely bad and despite all these
claims by the taliban that they
will not do anything against journalists
they will be
lenient to journalists and they will
respect human rights and will be
moderate
it looks it is not happening in
afghanistan at the moment the situation
is very bad
we should mention uh that dw has urged
the german government to help them will
they get evacuated
uh it's an ongoing process dw has
requested that they be evacuated from
afghanistan as their lives are in danger
uh it's not just dw many of the
organizations have joined hand and they
have all called on german authorities to
do something about it and i'm very
hopeful that the german government
berlin would look into it and they will
be evacuated but it is a difficult
situation it's a difficult process it's
not that easy
but we have our fingers crossed about it
that's uh shameless sham from dws asia
desk thanks for your insights
thanks for having me
president biden was keen to wrap up the
u.s mission in afghanistan by next
month's 20th anniversary of the
september 11th attacks the terrorist
strikes that prompted the u.s invasion
also motivated americans to join the
military in the war on terror but now
that the taliban are back in control in
afghanistan many are asking what the
20-year mission in the country achieved
dw's bastian hawtik spoke with one
veteran in new york city
the events of september 11 2001 changed
the world
and they also changed the life of dre
popov
forever
i saw a couple that was about i learned
later a little younger than myself they
had just gotten engaged that week and i
saw them hold hands jumping out of a
window
there were
343 firemen that knowingly went into
these buildings
aware that they're not going to come out
and then you look at yourself and say
what have i done for anybody besides
myself
so at 22 dre gave up his job as a
children's book illustrator and enlisted
as a u.s marine he was first deployed to
iraq and later to afghanistan
he could notice the difference their
presence made there we would see that
very often in towns if the radius and
the proximity to a u.s military base
meant that women were allowed to walk
freely without the escort of a man you
could see their face children were
playing outside there was a sense of
normalcy to some degree and the further
away you got from those military bases
the more they would start veiling and
covering themselves you wouldn't see
children playing outside
but the sense of normalcy came at a
great human cost more than a hundred and
seventy thousand people are estimated to
have been killed in the afghanistan war
some of them at dre popov's hands
something he says he's deeply ashamed of
no one has the right to take anyone's
life ever for any reason there's no
excuse
uh that that all of that immediately you
understand the moment that you're a
killer the moment you take somebody's
life you realize
how
disgusting
the very concept of doing that is
now as the taliban have taken back
afghanistan the question looms
was it all worth it the only thing
that's permanent was the death that we
caused but those
moments where you could see human
progress
i mean if it's temporary does it count
of course not as as the six-year-old
girl who learned how to read and then
got her eyes gouged out because she
learned how to read because we left and
that's going to happen across the
country
the us may be leaving afghanistan but
for veterans like dre popoff the war
isn't over it continues to be waged in
their minds
every day 22 u.s veterans take their own
lives because they can't live with the
guilt the memories the sense of being
excluded and abandoned by a society that
has moved on
to help veterans like himself popoff
co-founded the non-profit organization
veterans rebuilding life
they provide counseling reintegration
services and even job training
and medical aid to children in the
countries they fought in
a way to heal the wounds of war those of
its victims
as well as their own
i encourage the guys to come in to
remember
because it just means that you still
have a conscience and that you still
want to be a good person and when you
see them actually connecting with these
kids
it's impressive they don't drink anymore
they don't self-destruct they're not
angry they're not suicidal
they just want to help the next kid
it becomes their new addiction
and a constant reminder that on both
sides of the battlefield the fallout of
america's longest war will be felt for a
long time to come
you